bon tu es prête pour la rencontre je
suis ravie de rencontrer les parents
d'Alice c'est que ton père et moi on n
pas du gen à faire des manières alors
elle vous plaît voilà la beauté mais tu
es fou chéri jeprter à la concession
elle est même pas encore en vente c'est
une merveille tu sais papa ça sert à
rien de vouloir impressionner les
Bouvier sauvage oh je sais très bien que
ça va les impressionner mais je pas ça
pour ça bon allez mon dieu mais c'est
magnifique un peu froid mais
joli alors vous allez voir les viges
c'est là qu'il font leur V depuis des
centaines d'années on a bien fait
s'habiller quand même ouais moi j'ai
bien fait de pas pororter de pinard ça
en jettein pour chauffer
ça la
douill frédri Bouvier sauvage enchanté
Nicole et Gérard faisaient des
compliments sur le domaine ah ou oui
c'est une des plus belles propriétés de
toute la kit je vous fais courour oui
j'adore le billard alors moi je joue à
l'Américain oui bien sû comme dans tous
les bar PM chérie tu as raté quelque
chose quoi un jardin d'hivber magnifique
avec des orangers des qu'il est très
rare nous aussi on a un jardin d'hiver à
la maison on appelle ça une veréranda si
on a organisé cette rencontre c'est pour
vous dire que François a demandé ma main
et que j'ai dit oui on va se marier à
l'union de de nos deux familles oui on a
un petit cadeau pour vous le labo où je
travaille est américain ils nous ont
offert des tests ADN c'est un test qui
détaille toutes vos origines les
résultats les voilà he notre test ADN il
est sur les murs de ce château nous
sommes en France depuis Louis VI le Gros
ma chérie c'est un peu comme toi père
mes ancêtres sont connus depuis
longtemps je suis française et italienne
et voilà c'est tout enfin moi je suis
français depuis toujours alors si ça
peut vous faire plaisir j'ai rien à
cacher moi alors qui
[Musique]
commence
merde qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
connerie